Daniel in general it seems that Karl
sentiment is any business that Apple
decide to get into they dominate that
Apple ecosystem as soon you know
whatever it touches it somehow seems to
win that's not the case here oh yeah I
agree me babble put a little go on a
yogurt you know they'd they'd end up
delicious feet and pinkberry I think
that the key here is really about the
next markets for Apple I mean we talk
about Apple watch and wearables which we
believe is really off to a strong start
especially on the supply chain once that
gets fixed when we look at Apple TV I do
believe that they did shut that down
initially but into 2016 I I believe
Apple will come out with an integrated
TV part of it they needed to get the
streaming services so I think it's a
multi-step process I do believe the
apple TV will be a hang on a second
that's that's really interesting and it
suggests that what we read this morning
or last night in the wall street journal
isn't entirely accurate I think it's
true in terms that they did shut it down
the initial plans but I think as we look
out the next year Apple TV will be a
part of the product line when you say an
integrated TV you mean a televisions I
mean an actual television set and I
think this is some how could that be the
case if again I don't want to cast
aspersions on the reporting done by the
wall street journal they do lots of
great stuff but it's it seemed to me
reading that story that they had shut
this baby down that it's not how could
they bring out an integrated TV set next
year if they aren't working on it right
now yeah I think it's one of these where
the jury's still out in terms of which
direction appleheads and we talked about
this initial Apple TV which will be
launched at the developer conference
about us still the box that's still the
bakab are the streaming services I think
apple is tiptoeing into the apple TV so
I think it's one where temporarily they
have shut it down that's one hundred
percent accurate but I think as we look
forward you cannot say they're not going
to go into TV mark when you look at the
integrator the IOT Internet of Things
when you look at TV automotive and some
of these other areas given where Apple
is those are all potential
show total dress on markets that they
are gonna go after what do you think
about this argument the Carl Icahn is
making that apple stock looks so cheap
even if they're up fifty percent on the
year when you look at the PE compared to
the SP this thing's a steal it trades at
ten times X cash and at the end of the
day even though the stock is at a huge
run when you think about their growth I
mean next year and I knew where the
street underestimates you look at China
China we boobs 150 billion dollar market
opportunity for apple streets modeling
and seventy billion the growth for next
year apples six seven percent there's a
better chance of me playing in the NBA
than apple doing six percent growth I
like that I see it more as you know a
ten to twelve percent well what about
market technicals here we know how
heavily weighted index funds are
positioned in Apple they have to be but
mutual funds seem underweighted just
because they don't want to have that
much presence in a single name are they
gonna wake up one of these days
listening to you saying wait a minute
you in NBA vs apple and are suddenly
thinking to say wait a minute I gotta
get in this game and if they do given
how big mutual funds are I mean we're
just gonna see this thing on a tear and
even though I do have a decent jump shot
I think the key thing right here is
about them actually getting into
wearables we thing about the watch we
look at China I think this tree is
really under estimating some of the fuel
in the tank there but we have to balance
the two factors in the equation right on
the one hand there's how much money you
think Apple can make and then on the
other hand there's the valuation Carl
Icahn actually is conservative I'll call
upon the valuation he thinks Apple
should trade it 18 times what he expects
earnings to be and that's where you and
Carl differ I mean you're about on the
same camp that he is right at 19 times
you just think that next year Apple is
going to generate nine and a half
dollars of earnings a share whereas
Carl's out at 12 well I think nine and a
half is where the street is but I think
a number could be close to eleven
dollars given we talked about China what
when you look at the next year hang on a
second your report says nine dot 58 say
yes when you look at the 958 when you
look at what the upside potential here
is so it's watch the what's the Jews for
Apple right the street ones too what
me that upside it's China it's wearables
that's where you could get that extra
Apple ecosystem once people are in it
they never want to come out just
yesterday Eric you were going at the
multiple in which Yelp trades think
about the value proposition of Apple
versus so many of these tech companies
out there that are doing what for whom
and providing value but that doesn't
necessarily justify a higher valuation
for Apple all it says is that like the
yelp valuation is out of control yes but
all of those valuations that are out of
control do we really see them
normalizing or is there a higher
probability that Apple which actually
provides extraordinary value and makes a
ton of dough is going to move into their
direction apples the gold standard and I
think then the next step is really to
developer conference in a few weeks we
believe you know larger iPad they'll
give some breadcrumbs on a potential
Apple TV we look at the watch in terms
of unit growth and when are we going to
see that in retail stores these are all
key ingredients in that recipe for
success and it's really right now about
can Apple continue to show up side
numbers look what I believe it can be a
china china is front and center china's
the fuel on the tank for Apple it comes
down to its 150 billion dollar market
opportunity next three years streets
modeling 70 billion that's the upside
right there in terms of China try and we
believe chimes me the number one market
for this Apple watch alone how many
people you know and they're so hard to
find are wearing them and you're saying
do you love it right I don't know if I
love it but I obviously got one people
want to touch whatever Apple makes and
if you think it's a little bit here in
China it's extremely this has always
been the case right when was even when
Apple was trading at four hundred
dollars a share pre-split great people
loved Apple as much as they love today
it's so I think what Carla's saying
let's realize it let's take a closer
look and look at how this company is
performing look at their PE and realize
the value realize how much we like
Carla's just pounding the table for a
bigger stock buyback that's all he's
doing everything else is noise in terms
of the buyback in the 200 billion
capital allocation that they announced
that really was surface for the street
now it really comes down just like you
said is it
you love how do you see the multiple new
stock go higher it comes down to them
just continuing to deliver and you know
cook continuing to rely would make the
argument it's two loves if they didn't
make great products which they do that's
why look Apple has set a standard that
every other tech company just sits there
in their white board and marvels at and
wonders how they could look at China you
could Google you look at Microsoft let
other tech companies Apple has taken
time from fourteen percent of revenue
ultimately bleeds forty percent in the
next two years I think Tim Cook's when
we speak a man during the next few years
I don't care how much Siri hates me how
much my spellcheck keeps me down it's
hard not to like an apple phone I'm not
talking about the phone yeah so damn
great too great to have you here thank
you very much Dan eyes of FBR capital
markets